the fallout continues from the
incendiary comments made yesterday by
rich guy taking a dare way too far
Donald Trump when he haha seemed seemed
to imply encouraging violence against
Hillary Clinton not I mean didn't
thought out say it but there was an
implication CNN captured this gif of an
audience members real-time reaction to
Trump's thinly veiled Second Amendment
threat here it is oh-o-oh he shirt oh
that's rich he sure crossed a line mrs.
Claus
we're gonna precedent impossible death
threat against presidential nominee from
a rival candidate the Secret Service
wept into action leaving the White House
lawn exposed on social media by
releasing the following tweet The Secret
Service is aware of the comments made
earlier this afternoon that is mildly
passive-aggressive weirdly they follow
this up with an Arthur meme caption when
there's an assassination threat on bay
convenience the tone of the previous
Twitter post is pretty annoyed what's
another exasperated tweet we might see
from the Secret Service Jimmy Pardo
hey at Bernie Sanders your uber has
arrived all right yeah please get in it
Dave Krumholtz hey at real Donald Trump
there's only so much we can do so shut
the The Secret Service is tired of
tweets about the Netflix show stranger
things we're only on episode 2